And now the old scout master.
So I know this scout. he gets to be about 16, he gets his driver's permit and he gets his driver's license
and then he starts bugging dad about getting his own car.
And dad is a little reluctant to do this and he says I'll tell you what:
finish getting the God and country award you started working on last year
and maybe get your hair cut and then we'll talk about getting you a car.
So the scout really got a fire under him and he finished his religious award
and he asked his dad about getting a car and dad was glad to see that he'd earned the award,
but he still wanted him to get his hair cut.
His son replied he said he learned- I learned a lot about the Bible stuff in doing a religious award
and it turns out that all the guys in the Bible had long hair.
Moses had long hair, Samson had long hair, Jesus apparently had long hair.
Dad replies: yeah, did you also notice they walked everywhere that they went?
Oh no, no, they didn't. the son replied:
I know that the apostles had a Honda.
Dad looked a little confused and he said: how do you know that they had a Honda?
He says it says right there in the Bible, Dad, it says they were all in one accord.
They were all in one accord.
Oh my,
That was a really long trip to get to that joke. okay,
And that I have to thank. we're playing.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. this is Clark Green.
So we always start out by looking in the virtual mail bag, at virtual mail,
and the first piece of virtual mail is from iTunes. it's a review on iTunes.
You can put a review on iTunes. you know you can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
and if you go over there you can leave a review and a rating
And this is the vaunted five-star rating. I really appreciate that.
The best podcast on scouting, says Old Eagle Cub Dad.
He says I really wait each new podcast helpful and insightful information.
with someone who spent 25 years in the program, it doesn't get better than this.
Well, thanks so much, Old Eagle Cub Dad. I really appreciate your kind words.
And then, when Cousin wrote in, he says: thanks again for the insightful observations.
Scouter Harry. Scouter Harry is in the 68th London troop in London, Ontario, Canada.
He says: hi, Clark, another great podcast listen. this morning, as usual, on my hour and 45 minute commute,
The discussion with Blaise Vitale was interesting as our troop faces some of the same issues with the age range.
Our Scout program usually goes up to 14 and then the youth Mosey up to Venturers.
You play the late great Leroy Anderson's Bugler's Holiday as an intro to the panel discussions.
It's a wonderful piece of music and it puts me in mind that I played it as part of a regional honor program in 1981..
Wow, Harry, that's a while back, isn't it?
I can whistle the first clarinet part when you play it.
Well, thanks for being in touch, Harry.
And that's Harry Schneider. and Harry is actually going to be on the podcast next week
along with a couple of other Scouters from up in Canada.
Make sure to tune in next week and hear Harry and Dean Post and Tom Brewer talk Scouts Canada.
We had a lovely discussion and I'm looking forward to putting that together for the podcast.
Jeff Berg wrote in. he says I love the blog and the podcast.
It's become a regular visit for me.
I've also been spreading the word.
It's my small effort to make you an internet sensation.
Thanks, Jeff.
Oh, yes, an internet sensation.
That could go a lot of different ways, couldn't it?
Mike Brady says: thank you for the outstanding service you provide to all adult leaders.
Your weekly posts and podcasts help us stay focused on the essential elements of the Scouting program.
Keep up the great work.
Well, thank you for your kind words there, Mike.
I really do appreciate it.
Let's see here
This time around, in Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk a little bit about-
ooh, you could almost call this- ages and stages.
We're going to talk about developing youth leadership in younger Scouts
and kind of how to tailor your approach to that
Kind of an expansion of talking to Blaise Vitaly last week
and younger Scouts, newer troop, newer scout leader,
and it really got me to thinking.
And so in Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less,
we'll be going back and taking a look at that.
And then we have great email question that came in
and that should be enough for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less?
When we talk about youth leadership and scanning,
we have to talk about it in the context of the age of the Scouts,
the maturity of the Scouts,
the experience of the Scout leaders
and the experience of the Scout unit.
Those are all very important things.
Now, the basic principles of youth leadership.
they will apply in every sense.
but we need to remember that scouting and scouting principles
is not a one size fits all.
It gets tailored to individual situations
and that's part of the genius of the program.
Youth leadership in a Scout troop
has got to be developmentally based and progressive.
All youth leadership is based on the same principles
but they will not function exactly the same
and our expectations have to be scaled
to the age and the experience of our Scouts.
We don't start out, for instance, as a child
with a two wheel 22 speed mountain bike right
At the top of a really steep hill.
You know, I started out with a tricycle in the driveway
and then I moved on to a two wheeler with training wheels
and finally ended up pedaling away on my own
on my Schwinn 10 speed bike,
which, if you are a person of a certain age,
you will realize the magic of the Schwinn 10 speed
and you'll remember the excitement
of getting that racing bike.
So we're not going to start with a racing bike.
Let's start with an understanding that scouting
invests youth leaders with full responsibility
for making things happen.
It's not responsibility that's given to adults
who then dull this out.
The program really puts it right on the Scouts
and the Scouts have this responsibility-
we could say constitutionally-
and the reason that that's important to remember
is that the methods I'm about to explain-
we need to progress away from adult involvement.
as closely as I'm about to explain it,
We also need to understand. Scouts
get to make decisions and plans free from the coercion
and interference of adults,
but they are going to need their support
and they are going to need their advice.
So what I'd like to do is suggest a way forward
in given a particular situation.
let's say that you are a brand new Scout leader,
you have a group of brand new Scouts
who are 11 or 12 years old
and you have just started a brand new troop.
How do you go with youth leadership there?
I mean, you don't have the experience,
the Scouts don't have the maturity
and experience to put this together.
How are you going to be a youth led group?
Well, I'm going to suggest
it's best to begin with direct, simple choices.
I wouldn't start with a long presentation
about leadership based on a lot of abstract principles.
It's not going to work for guys who are 11 or 12 years old.
Work for some of them, but not for the great majority of them.
What I think we're looking for is something more like:
that's a tricycle, here's the pedals
and this is how you make it go forward.
This is how you steer it.
Quick stuff.
I get out the Scout Handbook.
If you look at the current edition of the Scout Handbook,
look at page 36 through 38.
Skip over the types of patrols
and you've got maybe half a dozen paragraphs there
about the subject: your patrol.
Let's say, you get those guys
and you stand up in a circle
and everybody has their Scout Handbook
and each one of the boys reads a paragraph
of that section of the book.
You don't take a whole lot of time
and explain and discuss things,
You just read the paragraphs
and then you can begin asking questions.
So you guys, how big should a patrol be,
Do you figure?
So this is going to be a patrol. then
Will that do for you?
Do you need to divide up into two patrols?
No, this is going to be a patrol.
So now you need to elect a patrol leader.
It says in the Scout Handbook
that patrols have names and they have flags
and all kinds of patches and stuff.
So do you guys want to do that?
Want to have a name and a flag and a patch?
Okay, well, I'll be back in five minutes
and tell me what the name and the flag
and the patches are going to look like,
what you're going to choose for a patrol name,
And then that probably took 20 minutes or so,
maybe 30.
And you did that at a Scout meeting
and that is probably about all you're going to do,
because with 11 or 12-year-olds
they're going to be very energetic
and they're going to be very interested
in playing a game right about then probably,
Or doing something other than standing around,
reading from a book and talking to you.
So that's fine,
You get 20 minutes, 15 minutes, 30 minutes, you know,
depending on the group,
the dynamics involved.
And then let's get to the next meeting
and the next time around
the patrol leader is working right alongside you
and they're reading another little section,
pages 48 and 49.
And that section is entitled
Where Do You Want to Be.
It'll only take a few minutes
and if each boy reads a paragraph of the section,
then they're not listening to you do it,
They're actually participating in it
and they're going to follow very closely
when they know that they're going to read.
So you read Where Do You Want to Be,
And this explains all the great stuff
that Scouts do in their troop and their patrol.
Okay,
And they read that
and you say, okay, Mr Patrol Leader,
let's make a list of five or 10 things
that you guys would like to try.
Now it might take, you know,
broadly leading questions on your part,
It might take some real digging,
but in the end you're going to have a list
of five or 10 things
and there goes, your 15 or 20 minutes is over.
That was a lot of hard work
and the patrol is ready to do something else.
They're ready to, you know, have a foot race
or, do you know, run around
and play a game or something.
And then maybe you get back
and for the last five or 10 minutes
you say: okay, guys,
put your hands together, out of these
five to 10 things, pick two or three
And once they have done that,
take your favorite out of the two or three
and take that home with you-
and you have some work to do-
Take that idea and develop it according to the method
you'll find on pages 49 through 52
of the Scout Handbook
and then bring that back to the Scouts
and explain it to them very quickly.
This is where you want to get out of stopwatch.
Now, that's meant to be literal.
I mean a literal physical stopwatch
and time yourself
and take about 10 minutes
at the very most, at the very most,
and when 10 minutes is up,
you just have to stop talking.
So what you're going to talk about
is you're going to go over
what you did to develop the idea
into a plan of action
and you'll tell them how you use
the information on pages 49 through 52
of the Scout Handbook to do that.
Show them that part of the Scout Handbook
and then talk about how you developed the plan.
You got maximum 10 minutes to do that-
extra points if you can get it in less-
and then ask who's going to develop the next idea
and if that plan works,
you know if they, like that plan,
say okay, can we use this for our first camp out?
You know, if they say yes,
then you're off and running
because now you start asking questions
around that plan.
Well, where are we going to go do this?
Does anybody want to check out
and see the different places to do this?
How are we going to eat while we're on the camp out?
Anybody have any ideas about that?
And you can use the pages that I'm talking about
and use exactly the method I'm talking about.
but don't be dogmatic about it,
and I'm not being dogmatic about it either.
What I'm trying to do is give you
the picture of a way
to incrementally develop this stuff.
You'll be very involved.
You work alongside the boys,
You try and draw some information out of them.
It will be halting and difficult to begin with,
but they're very energetic
and you watch and observe
and try and tap into that energy a little bit.
You know when it's time to play a game,
let the patrol leader lead the game.
You know in the first instance,
when we talked about them choosing a patrol name,
let the patrol leader lead that part
and then step back five or six steps
and watch and listen
without opening your mouth,
without signaling to them,
without doing anything, and just watch.
because what you're going to see is
relatively chaotic and messy
and two of the boys will run off and do this
and the patrol leader will be struggling
to keep the other three guys
to keep their attention,
and it's going to look horrible,
It's going to look absolutely horrible.
but within that horrible mess
you're going to see a small glimmer
of what you want to work with.
You're going to see that organizational planning
leadership glimmer there
and you'll see exactly
where you are and what you have to work with
and how you're going to build on this
incrementally, just a step at a time,
meeting after meeting, week after week,
month after month, year after year
and within a couple of years time
you're going to have a fully functioning
mature
boy led operation.
and it's done
just in those incremental steps.
It takes vision, perspective and determination
to do this.
You have to have a vision for what's going to happen
in the future and
you have to accept
the premise
that scouting is about youth leadership.
so you don't give up
because it's going to look horrible
to begin with,
but you have to accept that premise. don't give up.
and that's the vision.
You have to have the perspective that
it is going to happen incrementally.
it's going to happen
according to the abilities of the boys
and you have to be determined enough
to carry out that vision
and to maintain that perspective
and not to get lost
in the idea of
they're not really doing the things
the way that they actually should.
so I'm going to step in and do them.
It's just constantly working with them
and everything like that.
Even those of us who are veteran scout leaders
and who have troops
with pretty much so
autopilot programs
and experienced youth leaders.
we're still doing a lot of this
every single time.
we're still starting from square one
every year or six months.
so
go right to that scout handbook
and start picking things out.
keep it short, keep it on point
and look for those little glimmers of hope
that you see in the boys as you go along,
and it will all develop.
the program works. it really really does,
Music.
Hi, this is Dr Paul Auerbach
and you are listening to
Clark Green on the Scoutmaster podcast.
Write me a letter,
send it by name:
Music
Email. that is folks.
and here's an answer to one of your
emails:
Music.
So I got this email from Steve Boone
and Steve's a scoutmaster
of troop 920 in Winston-Salem, North Carolina.
He says: thanks so much for your
podcast. I've been a regular listener
for some time and learned a great deal about
scouting. I'm a new scoutmaster
since last June,
when my son and I joined the troop. one of my motivations
was the opportunity to spend some time
with my son, especially on camping trips.
As I've learned about the patrol method,
however, and how patrols
should cook and camp together, I'm
really getting kind of disappointed about losing time
with my son like sharing a tent
together. It doesn't seem like you do that
if you're working the patrol method.
Last week I had a dad
and a potential new scout visit our troop
who told me kind of the same thing:
he wanted to spend more time with his son.
he'd always wanted to take him camping but
somehow just never gotten it together to do it.
I'm interested in your thoughts on
how to reconcile what appeared
to be the conflicting goals of spending
time with our sons and working
the patrol method. Well, thanks for being
in touch, Steve, and I appreciate the kind words.
I'm glad you're getting something out
of this podcast and
I'm going to tell you that
my reply is going
to sound kind of discouraging
at first, but I want you to stick
with me because it gets better.
You and your son are
going to get the most benefit from
scouting if you'll follow the natural
progression of the program. Scouting
gradually progresses from parents being
pretty and closely involved in spending time
with their sons and tigers,
wolves and bears, weeblos-
to not being directly
involved at all
when they become boy scouts.
Scouting in a patrol in a troop
is not about creating father and son time
or mother and son time,
not in the way you've defined it.
far from it, in fact.
the process of scouting happens
when boys are working together and the adults
are really kind of only marginally involved
in most of the activities. That's the patrol
method. So
that means, just as you've discovered,
no sharing tense with dad,
no cooking with dad. there's a pretty
bright line there. There's no
reconciling the patrol method with
the goal of a parent and a son
spending time together. They're kind of at opposite
ends of the spectrum. Truth be
told, scouting was not conceived
with the idea of parents
being directly involved in
the process. But don't give up yet.
Don't give up. Stick with me. What you're
going to find, though-
working the patrol method and going along
with the progressiveness of the program-
is
not going to deny you something.
actually, it's going to give you something that is
even better. Okay, you're going to get
a lot of sharing with your son
and a lot of time with your son
out of scouting. As much as you love
the idea and cherish the idea of
that, father and son
camping and cooking and sharing a tent
and doing stuff together,
that way scouting is going to help
you grow closer and provides for some
incredible shared experiences. without that,
I've never known
any parent
who's involved with scouting
to regret having spent
the time in scouts with their
son. I've known
some who wish they had done a great deal more,
but I've never known anybody
to regret that time.
Well, you and your son won't be sharing
tents or meals or really spending a great deal
of time in each other's company during a scout
meeting or an outing. You're going to have plenty
to discuss outside
of scouting activities. Now that might seem
like a small consolation,
but I've got to tell you
this is an incredible
gift and I
can assure you that with the
perspective of years, because my son
and I we've been through the program for years,
and so what I'm telling you
is what my experience was:
That father and son relationship,
or that mother and son relationship,
is typically going to get
strained at some point
as boys pass through adolescence.
It's really
important that it gets strained. It's a healthy
process, because
a boy is going to be at odds with his parents
at one point. He's making his own way in the world
and he has to differentiate himself
from his parents and his family a little bit.
You know, it's a natural
process. It's a little scary, it's a little
off-putting, but it's a good thing
to have happen in the end.
Communications are strained
during these times.
That few minutes in the car
to or from a scout meeting,
that's a pretty incredible gift.
There may not be a whole lot of
words exchanged,
like I say when the
relationship is a little strained,
but there's going to be a reason to
talk about things. Having that
reason sometimes can be
a very big deal indeed.
Most boys new to a
scout troop are going to tend to stay
in their parents' orbit. if they're around,
if they're involved, They're going to
tend to stay in their parents'
orbit at first, but they
soon are going to start making their own way
with their fellow scouts. At first they're
going to be looking over their shoulder.
you know, is my dad over there?
is my mom over there? are they watching me?
are they paying attention to what's going on?
you know, will I be
okay? you know, do I need
to go ask them something?
but soon they're going to be
looking your way less and less until they're
fully confident and comfortable on their own,
and it's an incredibly important thing
for a boy to accomplish. Another
important aspect of this is you get to
share this with other parents. You'll
be sitting around a lot of campfires,
learning what the other dads and moms
are experiencing, and it's going to be
basically the same kind of challenges and
triumphs. You'll be able to give each other
some perspective and support
when things are difficult or when
things are going really well. you know,
and that's an immense consolation-
While you're taking refuge in the company
of these other parents, your
boy is taking refuge in the company of
other sons. My best friends
and confidants over the years have been
my fellow scouters and if you talk
to my son, his best friend
and confidants over the years have been
his fellow scouts.
When the time finally comes
and he's ready to make his own way in the world,
you'll be sending him off, having seen him
progress through the challenges of scouting.
He'll have
confidence, independence
and he'll have those life skills
that he needs to take things on that
others around him may not have.
It will make the transition
easier when he's ready
to move out and go to college. That's a tough
transition. It can be really tough,
but it's going to make it a little easier
for you because you've progressively let go
in a very conscious way.
Now, decades later,
you are still going to have
those scouting years that you
and your son shared together
and
it's kind of hard to put into words. There's a shared
understanding, there's a common language
and there's a real, enduring
comradeship
between a parent and a son
who have been in scouting.
The other thing I'll add
is that there's just absolutely
no way to explain how fast
all this happens.
Today
he's leaving the fifth grade
and joining a scout troop.
Tomorrow
he's graduating from college.
Next week he's presenting you with a grandchild.
It's going to blow your mind.
You won't believe how fast it all seems.
So I'm going to encourage you to rethink things.
I'm going to encourage you to trust
the scouting process and the program.
You're going to end up giving up
spending time with your son as you can see it now,
But you're going to
participate in something that I promise you
is infinitely richer
and it's going to be meaningful for the rest of your lives.
You can also subscribe to the Scout Master
podcast on iTunes
and when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review a rating. it really helps.
You can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about that
at Stitcher
S-T-I-T-C-H-E-R
dot com.
You can call and leave a voicemail, comment
or question at
484-734-0002..
You can also experience
the best panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right. Follow us at
Scout Master blog on Facebook,
Tweet Scout Master CG on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
Scout Master CG circle,
Search for Scout Master CG on Google Plus,
So you don't mess
with that Facebook thing
or the Twitter thing
or none of the plus stuff.
That's alright. You can email me, Bunky.
That's right. Your comments and questions
and ideas are always welcome
at Scout Master CG
at Verizonnet,
at Verizonnet.
The Scout Master blog and the Scout Master podcast.
they're not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America
and they're not endorsed by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, No, no,
It's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to Scout Leaders
and hopefully have a lot of fun along the way.
Before we leave you today,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert
Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir?
Until next time.